you know from crazy x and trolls world
tour where she plays barb
please welcome very funny my friend
rachel bloom hi rachel
you're my friend too hi moses what a fun
intro i did
it was really good and i love how much
you love being a host of a show like
this
and i love it why you clearly take
in talking to comedians and celebrities
uh
during a pandemic where there are so
many more important things happening
absolutely i love to pull focus to bomb
in my living room
you know there's so many voices we
should be elevating right now and i like
to
cut through all that noise use the tbs
algorithm to get my voice
projected up there and and just bomb in
the place that i
just lay down for 23 hours out of the
day
and then do this is classier than i
pictured it
yeah i tried it's nice i tried a little
bit
i'd want like a job i want to perform so
i was like
please let's make this as good as
possible it's very nice that means
getting great
gas wow smooth transition
i wanted to talk to you specifically
because i feel like you've had a crazier
quarantine
than most people yeah i mean
not only have you been personally
affected by this and
and losing a good friend but you also
had a very unique situation where you
had a baby
in quarantine which is already it's
already insane to have your first kid
right this is the first kid that you're
talking about that i know
yeah oh you can bring actually i want to
breastfeed during this entire
conversation yeah yeah you can come
absolutely
yeah before is that dan uh no it is
uh it is our nanny because i'm in a
position where i can
uh have a nanny and that is why uh
anyone
who's on television explaining how
they're quarantining right now
uh what they're not talking about is
their immense privilege absolutely
so it's very easy for these celebrities
to sing uh
four lines of imagine and say that
everyone should stay inside and and do
their part
because they don't have to i'm not i i
am one of the least famous famous
people i think in the world and i'm also
really not that rich
i have a pool i say that about you all
the time yeah a least famous famous
person truly and you have a pool so it's
so much
nice i really can't like i mean i can
complain
i can't really like i can i can
convention about certain things but like
i'm not going to pretend
let's not pretend that i'm in a position
of um not being fortunate
during this quarantine despite the fact
i lost someone despite the fact i had a
baby despite the fact it was
the most emotionally intense and
traumatic thing i've ever been through
i'm still doing well hello
look at this this is fine this is uh
yeah i i can't believe more people don't
do this i'm always so embarrassed of
where we are in the culture when i'm in
an airport when airports are still a
thing
and there's a whole insane booth for
moms
to breastfeed in that you have to go
into like it's this
i'm sorry i'm sorry pervert thing so
well yeah it's like it's not my fault
that you
can't like sexually control yourself
around a woman doing
feeding a human being yeah like i'm i'm
sorry it's it's once again it's the
whole
well it's of course the whole biblical
thing of
it's against god for a man to spill his
seed unnecessarily right
yeah and that's right that's like you'll
go to hell if you spill your seed
unnecessarily and so what that is is
women shouldn't be indecent
because it will cause the man to spill
his seed
unnecessarily so i i have to like put on
a whole cover
while feeding my child so you don't like
jizz on my feet yeah control your seat
control your scene
slipping all over it is my that's what i
imagine
will happen in an airport if this is
allowed
abomination is allowed yeah i really
have
i mean i look i've never been a i've
never been like a
a blushing flower with this so i can't
claim like
oh my god i used to be so shy no i'm an
exhibitionist but that having been said
my entire neighborhood has seen me has
seen my breasts because i've been
breastfeeding on my patio because it's
the most comfortable place to breastfeed
and i
get out there yeah well the thing that
you kind of take to the next level
is you have a projector and you have a
large screen on a blimp
that's floating around the neighborhood
i want people to see it i want people to
know and you know
my vagina is a mess yeah you see photos
yeah well it was making a cute face in
one of them
it would be and say also if it wasn't um
if mess if it was like
everything was fine yeah no and i don't
think that's a mystery no one says like
your vagina is great
after giving birth but it's but it is
this whole thing where um
you have to literally the only way i was
able to cope is you wear these
these cold packs yeah they stick they're
like
they're like super sized menstrual pads
but they're but they're uh
cold and you basically wear it against
yourself and it
numbs you it's so easy to be a woman i
thought about that
constantly what a great experience a
great experience but i mean it's just
spilled his seed once and then he was
done
oh yeah listen i definitely i definitely
had the [ __ ] end of the stick as far as
giving birth but
he doesn't like gross medical stuff me
neither my girlfriend just watches like
pimple popping videos and surgery shows
and then huh
no i think the miracle of life i would
watch that
i was prepared for him to faint and he
didn't um
it's gory i mean it's a it's a gory gory
it's a gory thing and you know you get
stitches
but but i had i i got off topic but
i just anyone watching you normalize
that i think you should do that on your
patio next kid
yeah oh yeah on my patio yeah i mean
the great thing is i had an epidural and
that's great
i just i can't i can't recommend it
i just enough i can't recommend it
enough
because the idea
that you look i it's very personal
everyone makes their own decision i have
friends who opted for no pain relief
during labor and that was a very
personal choice
for me i definitely felt a little
pressure of
oh well unless you are like feeling the
full pain of labor
are you really doing it and that is such
i think um
it's not patriarchal but it's some sort
of
my husband said it's the equivalent of
guys being like how how how
how much can you lift right
right you're really doing it what am i
what am i doing i'm not
i'm not having a kid to have labor pain
i'm having a kid to have a kid
my mom had all home births uh
no drugs in a kiddie pool um because you
know they were in a cult
and uh i could not say enough things
against it
don't do it go to a hospital you're
breastfeeding dan's working on his
garden his very sad
guard oh this is so dan
have you been gardening hey gregor hey
dan
why haven't you returned my moses wants
to ask you about your quarantine garden
on team coco live
writer on crazy acts multiple deadline
articles
for
how are you why haven't you answered my
texts and vemma requests for money
i uh don't think you deserve it ah
come on just used to having so much
money this is
taking a real hit so is this garden real
you posted a photo of this
this very small carrot oh it's so sad
i did make a real garden i put it by the
sprinkler head
because i didn't i don't think that i'm
responsible enough to uh to water
plants every day i'm not um and um
and then i'd say within the first 24
hours
um animals had eaten 50 of the garden
um and uh and then
um i think then it's been four months
now we've been in quarantine
right and i was like hey four months you
have a squash or something
something i want something and so i
finally dug up a couple things i saw a
little nub of carrot sticking out and i
was like oh
all right time for a salad baby and uh
the old carrot salad the whole carrot
salad and uh it was
just a little nub of a thing and it's
really sad and pathetic and i don't
think um
i don't think i know what i'm doing i've
failed at making bread
i failed at making salad
this is bad i think you start hunting
this is gonna get a lot of comments in
the chat but i think these animals are
clearly drawn to it i think this is how
you're gonna grill some possum wait one
second uh brooklyn
i'm just gonna have the baby here we go
i
i know someone that didn't have a cute
kid and i'm just been like you know
it's right that's a good kid that's that
kid's gonna be an influencer i'm sorry
to tell you
oh no so that is our biggest fear is
she's already like an
la kid growing up with like parents in
the industry
and i just can't i can't
i can't yeah can't
the makeup no i i wouldn't i wouldn't
wish this life on anyone
to to constantly run i mean dan's a
performer as well as a writer it's like
the idea that you're always trying to
seek attention and you're risking
humiliation and rejection to
get a hit is the baby is there any like
songs you sing to the baby
i do a lot of um a lot of chubby checker
a lot of uh yeah
so for anyone that's not 49 chubby
checkers
i mean seven figures for those 100
you're pretty young on twitch
all right this is on twitch um what a
great place our careers are in we're on
twitch
if you don't know chubby checker
obviously you know fats domino oh
yeah absolutely you know blueberry hill
being like a pretty big hit
from uh from that uh i do have a fun
exercise we used to do her because
apparently
chubby checker named himself chubby
checker just because fats domino
was successful so he was like okay i'm
going to take a synonym for fat
and then another day for a game and then
so fats domino chubby checker and so i i
my favorite is uh tubby clue um
and but there's a there's like corpulent
shoots and ladders
what a what a career path just go on
name alone
obese monopoly yes oh base monopoly
these are all great
yeah it's a fun roster on my record so
for my name if someone was going to rip
off me
which you know if you wanted a career on
twitch
abraham tornado oh that's good oh god
that's better than moses storm
that's actually or impossible as a name
abraham tornado
that's pretty good oh yeah wow influence
your name
solomon twister
somehow more jewish than my name king
king david typhoon
king david typhoon that comes with a
free birthright trip
that's he's a famous wrestler i loved
him